If you got 5x minus 2y equals negative 4, you did a great job. Let's see how we
got that answer. Remember, the first thing we have to do is find the slope
between these two points. We know that the equation for slope is y2 minus y1
over x2 minus x1. Now, to make sure I put the values in the right places, I
always label one of the my points, x1, y1 and the other point, x2, y2. That way,
I make sure I plug them into the right places. So when I find the slope, y2
minus y1 is, y2 is 7, minus y1 is negative 3 over x2 which is 2 minus x1 which
is negative 2. 7 minus negative 3 is 10. 2 minus negative 2 is 4 and 10 over 4
can be reduced to 5 halves. So we know that the slope of our line. So we know
the slope of our line is 5 halves. Now that we know the slope, we can find the
equation of the line. In order to find the equation of the line, we use the
equation m equals y minus y1 over x minus x1. Now I plug in what I know. The
slope is 5 halves, and that's going to equal y minus y1, y1 is negative 3 over x
minus x1 which is x minus negative 2. Let's go ahead and write these again. 5
halves equals y minus negative 3 is y plus 3 and x minus a negative 2 is x plus
2. Now I can simply cross multiply. When I cross multiply, I have 5 times x plus
2 equals 2 times y plus 3. I have to remember to distribute. After I distribute,
I have 5x, plus 5 times 2 is 10, equals 2y plus 2 times 3 is 6. Since I want
this equation in standard form, I'd need the x and y terms on the left side and
the constant on the right side. So, I can subtract 10 from both sides to move
the constant over to the right. And I have 5x equals 2y minus 4. 6 plus negative
10 is negative 4. And then I have to subtract 2y from both sides. And I get a
final answer of 5x minus 2y equals negative 4.